today I'm going to be speaking with
Chris Tarbell former FBI special agent
and now founding partner at naxo was
involved in the eventual takedown of the
Silk Road which I've spoken a little bit
about before Chris great to have you on
today really appreciate it ah thanks for
having me on David I appreciate it so
you know to start just somewhere as I
read about the story of how uh Ross
Albrecht and and the Silk Road will were
ultimately taken down one of the things
that is often described as the story is
told in many of the books about it is
that it's really like the prototypical
example of different law enforcement
agencies in the U.S not working well
together which is sort of like this
narrative that often exists about well
the FBI wants credit well this also
involved HSI and it involved all these
different agencies and the Silk Road
would have been taken down much sooner
were egos put aside that's a story
that's often told do you think that
that's fair as far as the way way that
it went
uh no not exactly
um you know the the other agencies were
doing good investigations HSI had good
investigations going as far as going up
the chain
um but unfortunately this is a new way
of dealing drugs I mean this was
um you know they were the buyers didn't
know who the dealers were the dealers
didn't know who the admins were
um you know and so it really was just
you know it didn't go the normal
investigative route you know I wanted
this new Cyber route so for people who
don't know what what the Silk Road was
can you give them sort of a brief
synopsis I mean it was it was a dark web
site that was originally I believe uh
dealing mostly in illegal drugs but
actually came to be much more than that
yeah it was an online uh dark Market
website uh operated on the Tor Network
with the onion router this was a hidden
network developed by the Navy uh back in
the late 90s and you can't trace IPS
traditionally through it there it works
on a different protocol that kind of
hides where the traffic is coming from
and going to uh but it also worked
through anonymity through cryptocurrency
this was the early stages of Bitcoin so
you literally could go on there and buy
almost anything it was a 1.2 Billion
Dollar Empire by the time we took it
down
um now there were two things you
couldn't Buy on Silk Road
um you couldn't buy guns because that
was on a different website and you also
couldn't buy fake IDs all right sorry
fake um college degrees you could buy
fake IDs you couldn't get a fake call
college degree they didn't want you to
be uh like a doctor
um and uh and not really have the
education when this started to become an
investigation that involved multiple
agencies
what was really or let me put a
different way what were their concerns
about where it could go or was the
concern really what was already taking
place with it
um really it was what was already taking
place
um you know in the FBI and I can't speak
for HSI or IRS or DEA in their
investigations
um the FBI investigation really came out
of we had a lot of cases around that
time it was 2011 2012. a lot of cases
just ended uh it was Tor we can't do
anything about it
um so we had just done a big case
involving Anonymous and the arresting of
Sabu Hector montagueor and one of the
other guys on on the anonymous case was
a guy named Jeremy Haman and he was
arrested and he was using Tor so it was
one of those interesting things we
didn't do anything
um with tour it just happened that's how
he's hiding and it took us an extra six
months to find him but once that case
was over we started sitting around and
thinking about maybe we should take a
look at tour and see what we can do
there's so many cases being closed
um just because it's it comes up as a
tour IP address if I recall correctly a
big kind of breaking point in starting
to look at Ross Albert was someone
involved in the investigation and it's
been a little while since since I I read
the the book about the investigation
someone put together
an old handle that Ross used on some
Message Board which then they figured
out oh they're that that's I recognize
that that's also appearing elsewhere
remind us of that detail but maybe more
importantly how long did the Silk Road
investigation go before the name Russell
brick ever actually was mentioned
well so that there's a there's a path
there there's a story there that that
you know it's kind of difficult so
there we the connecting the the word the
name you're looking for is Frosty yes so
someone on a on a message board way back
at the start of Silk Road posted uh uh
hey I'm starting this onion site and
it's going to use cryptocurrency if
anybody has any programming help reach
out to me at Frosty
um and when I was posted in the username
frosty in the Forum right they said
reach out to me at ross.olbrick
gmail.com right which again is a clue in
our world yes um not until we found the
server and was able to go through sort
of the networks of the server and find
that uh there was a backup server in
Philadelphia
um and then there was a computer that
was reaching out to the backup server
and the name of the computer was Frosty
um so now we have you know this this
computer being run by DPR dreadfire
Roberts the guy who operated Silk Road
um you know and then this posting of
from Frosty with the email address Ross
Albrecht gmail.com and that was
originally the way that the
investigation turned to look
specifically at Albrecht
yeah I mean we had to develop a few
other things before we knew that he was
in the Pacific coast time uh because
there was a jabber server uh that he had
set up that's a communication server for
his admins to talk on and we knew that
his time frame was around then but that
specifically that was the where we
connected Ross through that Frosty
connection if you look at um critiques
of the way that Albrecht was ultimately
prosecuted it seems what most often
comes up is something along the lines of
you know the drug part increasingly
there's a view that drugs should be
decriminalized at minimum many should
actually be legalized more commonly with
cannabis than with cocaine but this is
sort of like the way things have kind of
moved over the last decade 15 years
particularly Libertarians like Albrecht
subscribe to that ideology and there are
many who say that were it only the drugs
alone really what was happening
shouldn't actually have been against the
law however it went over into you could
hire Hitmen on the Silk Road and it went
over into all this other stuff that I
think is more universally thought of as
like you know that that stuff definitely
shouldn't be legal when someone like you
or others in the FBI are investigating
something like this how much or do does
it matter at all what your personal
feelings are about for example which
drugs if any should be illegal or
decriminalized or legalized or does it
quite literally never enter into the
work as you are investigating something
like this
it really never enters into the work I
mean so I I was assigned to New York I
was a special agent in New York and and
I like to say in New York you know it's
so specialized there's uh you know let's
I jokingly say there's a bank robbery
and the first question is was the bank
robber left-handed or right-handed
because there's one Squad handles left
in bank robbery the others handles
right-handed
um you know where you're put on a squad
and we were very we were criminal cyber
intrusions
um so we were the hacking criminal
hacking crew um that was that was our
Squad and there's another Squad that did
National Security hacking so really you
know I was just investigating and
hacking um and really tour had come up
um we had partnered up with start with
Southern District of New York who had a
case with uh the DEA at the time and
then brought in the IRS and so really I
was looking at 18 USC
um 10 30 violation of hacking rules and
that was one of the things sold on Silk
Road was was hacking tools or hacks for
hire
um and so that was sort of the Nexus but
really there when we opened up the Silk
Road case we opened up 25 other onion
sites and it really was more looking
into using Tor as a way of hiding
criminal activity
when you see the sentence that Albrecht
ultimately got which was I believe two
life sentences without the possibility
of parole does 40 years plus 40 years
okay does that seem like the right
sentence for what he did
that is not my decision you know I'm I'm
part of the you know that's the thank
God the government has different
branches you know I'm part of the I was
part of the executive branch no doubt
the laws
um you know the legislative branch does
the you know what laws there are in the
judicial branches come up with the
punishment so that that's way beyond my
scope of expertise no but as a guy who
now is out and just might have an
opinion I I really don't have an opinion
on it yeah and I I'm not suggest I don't
know that I mean sometimes people say
that because they don't want to answer I
I actually am open to the idea that you
really just that's not the way you think
about these things you have a particular
role in this whole thing
yeah certainly I I mean I I I'm not I
wouldn't be upset if uh someone I
arrested you know was let go um I mean I
wrecked I arrested Hector montagueor uh
he spent you know months in jail was
facing 125 years but did a great job I'm
not offended by all the work I put in
and he got out and didn't got got he was
only in prison for for nine months for
for what he did
um you know that doesn't offend me in
any sort of way that so yeah I really
don't have an opinion on it what's the
current state of dark web marketplaces
because it's not really a topic in the
news right now but it's sort of like by
definition the idea is it's dark web so
you don't necessarily know about it
these aren't indexed websites you need a
special browser to access it do you know
much about the current state of these
types of marketplaces I do I'm still
involved in them so yeah um you know you
would ask me right after Silk Road and
right after Ross got sentenced all that
you know two life sentences in 40 years
I would have said it would have gone
down I would no one would do this it's
crazy but it actually exploded right
after that
um there was a big um state of you know
people setting up these sites and
stealing people's cryptocurrency but now
it's becoming to you know there's places
you know and I don't want to tell kids
how to get there right
um you know but but there are many many
dark Market websites out there that you
can still still do many more than they
were back in the day are they ever based
in the United States or is that just
like the height of of ignorance to
approach it that way
you still do it in the United States um
you know it's it's sort of a
whack-a-mole someone makes a mistake a
configuration issue or something like
that and law enforcement gets them
um but the latest takedowns haven't
really used infrastructure in the United
States that I've seen you mentioned the
connection to crypto and that crypto was
often the payment method that was used
one of the interesting and full
disclosure I have no emotional
attachment to this question I also have
no opinion I was in not early but you
know 2016 I bought some Bitcoin and it
did really well and I've mostly sold all
of it and I have no opinion as to where
it's going or how much it's used for
criminality one of the arguments that
was made earlier about Bitcoin was it's
overwhelmingly used for criminal
activities but my understanding is that
when the Silk Road was shut down the uh
throughput of transactions barely
changed at all which sort of would be a
Counterpoint to the idea that Bitcoin
was primarily being used for criminal
transactions did you you and your
investigative work come to have an
opinion about that and and how regularly
criminal motivations were were at play
for Bitcoin transactions
so you know in my world as an FBI agent
I only looked at criminal activity so
you know I saw it attach it to
everything I mean it really was the
birth of ransomware I mean we've had
encryption for you know 75 years you
know digital encryption that sort of
thing all the way back to you know the
Nazis uh uh encryption you know their
Enigma machines
um you know so that's not new what
really was the rise for ransomware was
the popularity of cryptocurrency
um so you know we're fighting we're
still fighting that to this day on that
sort of thing
um so you know I am a technologist I
liked cryptocurrency I see the point of
it I liked it you know two people can
meet in a far-off place and making
transaction and it's locked in place
within you know 60 minutes at most
um but I see a lot of criminal activity
connected to it what are you seeing now
in terms of the trends of the cyber
threats scams fishing at the individual
level if you're able to comment on it
you know about five years ago I was
getting a lot of the hey you owe tax
money and we're sending the police to
your house to which I would say send
them sounds interesting obviously I know
I don't you know I'm not giving you any
money Social Security scams give us
access to your computer and we'll like
log into your bank that that sort of
stuff I'm not being targeted by that
anymore I'm getting a lot more sort of
like telemarketing stuff like wanting to
sell me warranties on vehicles I don't
even have and this sort of thing what
are the trends right now what's going on
so we're seeing a lot of fishing scams
for uh crypto theft so any sort of like
accounts that are taken over where it's
uh sent out that you're part of a crypto
network if you're part of an exchange
you know you'll start getting a lot of
phishing emails and the the fishing the
the phone calls
um give me access and then because it's
so easy you don't have to they give
access to their computer and all and you
know just take the the wallets right out
right there you don't have to convince
them to do anything more I think one of
the biggest Trends and so I host a
podcast with Hector monzagor um Sabu the
guy arrested hackering the fed and he
made a prediction and I agree with him
that this year we're going to see a lot
more Insider threats people inside
networks who we give access to
um are going to be stealing data um you
know he kind of made that prediction
based on the the large technology
layoffs we've we've seen lately
um but we're seeing more and more you
know networks have been protected from
the outside and very few people are
doing things to protect internal Network
stuff what's the lowest hanging fruit
right now just for individuals in terms
of protecting themselves
what can they do better yeah I mean it
you know I know people who for example
they just don't pick up their phone
anymore and just by doing that unless
they they quite literally know who's
calling them even if they think it might
be their bank they just do not pick up
the phone as an example and that right
there knocks 50 down or you know that
type of thing yeah no I would definitely
do that you know the the email stuff is
still the phishing stuff but one of the
easiest things you can do is called
segmentation
um there's no much no more flat networks
at work you'll never see just one router
and everyone connects to the same router
in any office but we're seeing that at
home still a lot of people just have one
router they give their passwords out to
people that come and visit or or and
that sort of thing or when they connect
internet other things when your
thermostat is connected to your router a
lot of thermostats and things like that
um have hard-coded passwords or they
don't change the administrative
passwords well that's a whole right into
your network so
um segmentations either through vlans or
having physical different devices
um have you know more than one router in
your house in and secure it that way oh
that's interesting so for example you
could you could set up a separate Wi-Fi
network for the thermostats alone and
you on your phone never connect to that
Network yeah anything you do banking on
should not be on the same as your
Internet of Things
um especially things that punch what I
call punching holes in the firewall so
because you can change your thermostat
from outside your house right because
you can look at cameras that you've had
connected to your internet those are
holes in your firewall
um that means that they you know it's an
entry point into the the defense system
um so you know have a different network
that doesn't have that connected to it
used for your you know banking uh
logging into banking accounts and that
sort of thing all right that's useful
and actionable and it's not unrealistic
you know sometimes the tips you read are
like yes I could do that but I'm
basically segregating myself out of the
way Society is operating
it's like a diet that you can only
sustain for a week it's not super useful
long term yeah
um
it's really a thing you can do and you
know configuration there's a lot of
YouTube videos out there that can help
you configure you know different
networks we have been speaking with
former FBI special agent Chris Tarbell
now a founding partner at naxo Chris
really appreciate your time and your
insights today
thanks so much for having me on I
appreciate it it was fun